so there was a time when I was about to
give up and was actually right before I
met you guys so I'm gonna be in emotion
I had gone through something really girl
and family stuff and sometimes I can get
it really hard and I was forced to move
away somewhere
I had never been Thurman Lingam and I
knew no one
but I also blend it in there so no one
really knew me at the beginning but I
know you guys you're so worn such bright
lights I'm so happy
I'm so glad picture this one this time
with me because it reminds me about time
and help farmer cotton and how far we
might have been there now because I
found my lights and you guys help me
stick through it don't really like round
so who knows really thankful for that
time
um eighth grade I lost a really close
friend of mine it was an accidental
suicide at that point I really didn't
know like how to control my emotions I
let all of my emotions get the best of
me and whatnot and I thought I really
couldn't handle it and I didn't really
talk to people after the passing and
then four days after my 14th birthday I
tried to
overdose obviously didn't succeed thank
God but yeah I guess just talking not
talking to people about it and just
keeping it all in and just pretty happy
to like pretend that I was strong and I
had to be strong for others put a lot on
me after that I just learned how to cope
with things and I started talking to
people and yeah I'm really happy with
myself yeah
oh gosh this is very personal
but um I was in college and my
ex-boyfriend got me pregnant and I
miscarried I wanted to give up on school
but something kind of just told me to
continue and then the whole ex-boyfriend
thing didn't work out anyways but yeah
that was definitely a time I just wanted
to give up and honestly just kind of end
my life but I didn't I attempted but I
moved past it all got help from my
family and friends kind of opened up to
them about it and yeah I definitely was
very far away see you guys I didn't want
to open up about it so I was still young
and I didn't want anyone to know but
when I finally opened up to like my
close friends they were understanding
about it and then to my older sister who
had no idea about it and she was very
supportive then I actually started
seeking therapy my family didn't know it
kind of went behind their
back and because my daddy didn't really
believe in therapy he's like whatever
like don't need it kind of thing but he
didn't know what happened to me until I
told him kind of kind as a note to list
day I think he kind of he senses it but
just opening up to friends family and
then talking to my counselor at school
whom I told like I wanted to give up on
school but I did it and they just all
pushed me so yes yes actually last year
in February I attempted suicide because
growing up I always struggled like
myself and then I always brought down by
my by my mom and then I was sexually
assaulted my junior year it was
triggered a lot of things which lets his
self-harm and then attempted suicide and
I was like my darkest days I'm glad
you're staying there thank you
what helped you get through it I'm
definitely my family and I did seek help
I went to therapy for a while was on
medication which I did not like but I'm
actually clean I'm a year clean of
self-harm due to like my sister she
helped me a lot yeah oh she helped me a
lot and my little brother he was born
like a year ago and he's helped me a lot
too just all the positivity and also go
to church
[Music]
completely giving Polly yeah not too
long ago actually is about a few months
ago earlier this year I was kind of like
a little lost I guess I didn't know what
my purpose in life was I don't know what
I wanted to do is so it's just like it's
like waking up every day and it's like
I know it was hard to get up for no
reason like I had stuff to do but it was
really hard to get up inside I don't
know
as far as heart sings playing really
but yeah I'm doing much better now
though I was getting sick of it like I
just wanted I just didn't want to get
stuck in that like phase in my life so I
just decided to get up like just make
your bed simple things like that
a little bit ago my my dog died and I
understood it was just a really small
thing to a lot of people it happens over
and over again in people's lives things
die but I guess it was something that
kept me tethered and made me realize
that it's the people around me that make
me happy and it's such a small group and
one of them was gone and I I realized
that the more people I met the more
people would disappear and meeting
people is part of growing up and for a
second there I didn't know that I could
do it I didn't think I couldn't meet
more people or could grow up but uh
I got another dog and I met more people
and somebody told me that
looking back on memories it's like
looking through a window and you still
appreciate the things and the people
that were there but you're not on the
other side of that wonder anymore
I guess that Tyler not to give up Vector
not wanting to grow up really it's been
within the last year with school just
the I don't know exactly what I want to
do and a that as well as I recently came
out to my parents and work it's all it's
like a multi-faceted attack on me it's
not directed by any one person but all
of that coming at me at once it's made
me just want to give up and I have to
fight like every day to just like keep
going I was in I was in high school I
[Music]
had a really really rough probably a few
months with my parents
and I didn't have many close friends I
had friends but I didn't feel anything
past like I guess like companionship and
then I guess I just kind of lost hope in
any type of future yeah so it was mostly
just because I I couldn't connect with
anyone for a while I don't have anything
like complex to say like I was not in
control of what was happening around me
even when I was acting or speaking I was
sort of almost like autopilot constantly
and then during really low points
I was just convinced that there was
absolutely no reason I need it to be
here I started thinking about my future
a little bit and I started thinking
about my family I guess I knew that
people cared about me enough and even
though I didn't feel it I I understood
it logically and that was enough to pull
me out of it I guess so I used to battle
with anorexia about two years ago I felt
like giving up I woke up one day and I
just said this is
I want to do it anymore I was like I
don't want to give up and I just said
you know what I'm gonna keep continuing
so what made you change your mind and
just keep going uh I thought about my
family friends my dreams that I would
never succeed in and I didn't if I gave
up so what are you dreams to move to
America did that come true yes time to
pick one I think
there have been a lot of times
throughout my life so I don't really
have like one heartfelt interesting
anecdote about it something more that
I've been realizing it's like a chronic
issue that has been throughout my life
like going back and reading my journals
there have been a lot of moments where I
have thought about giving up but I'm
glad I have it thank you it's a lot of
feeling hopeless and in despair and so
dark and that there's no way to get out
and then I'll never get out of feeling
that way but I always do what helps
antidepressants music watching YouTube
videos until it passes I've never really
felt maybe like completely giving up but
there's been times when I just have no
direction and I don't know what to do
and especially in college my first year
in college was really rough and my
family was overseas I was kind of alone
in America and they were just times when
I
had no idea what I was doing and I just
kind of ended up literally wandering
around on the street and I had there was
more than one time when a homeless guys
would come up and be like are you okay
and I ended up like talking and having
good conversations with homeless guys
who were just trying to make sure that I
was going to be okay and and it was is
really neat that you know other people
reached out when I clearly not in a good
place and that's what helped me get
through it like you literally think that
those people asking you how you're doing
is how you got through it I really do I
mean I I honestly and I know this is
like crazy for so many people but I
literally believe that they were angels
this mission one particular night I was
wandering around and I was there was a
river running through Wilmington and I
was sitting right next to the river and
I guess I looked like I was about to
jump and and one guy came up to me and I
had seen him you know view zola's man
that was around often and he came up to
me and he was like oh goodness are you
are you okay do you need to talk and I
just ended up talking to him and his
name was Jason and we had an interesting
conversation about how he became
homeless and you know the struggles that
we both kind of were going through and
it was really me but yeah that really I
helped me feel like I wasn't alone if
you could if you could say something to
Jason right now or we could talk oh my
goodness I just want to hug him again
because he I don't think he knows how
much he impacted me and I don't know
where he is or what he's doing or if
he's okay but he clearly had nothing and
when I hugged him he was so bony but he
he reached out in my time of need and I
just have to thank him for that so I'm
trying to start a club at my high school
and the administration told me that I am
not allowed to do it because it's mental
health-related and that would be a
liability and instead of giving up I
just talked to one of my teachers who I
know agrees with me about the issue and
wants to help me solve it and we took it
to
curriculum director and are working on
changing the minds of the administration
it's called the resilience project and
it's designed to help people empower
themselves to ask for help when they're
struggling so what made you want to
start a club like that my community has
mentality were beautif and we kind of
just believe that we can get through
anything by ourselves and because of
that we have a really big suicide
problem and I think if we kind of change
the conversation about mental health and
work towards being strong enough to ask
for help instead of being strong enough
to face it alone then we'll be able to
fix the problem or help solve it hi
everyone thanks for watching another
episode basically I just want to say
welcome to the new subscribers and to
the subscribers who have been with me
for a while I want to thank you for
constantly supporting my channel that's
pretty much it thank you guys again for
everything and I'll see you next week